the livestream that's starting at 7:00
Eastern tomorrow night for Pacific
twitch and YouTube Comedy Central's
YouTube feed Twitter and so many more
spots for you to go check it out and
part of that live stream to make people
laugh and raise money for those who are
suffering from koban 19 certainly in the
comedy world is our buddy
the roastmaster general himself Jeffrey
Ross how are you Jeffrey Ross hey big
rich great to hear from you pal come on
I love you so much
I don't care who knows it what's this
livestream about Jeff your art is as big
as your comedy game and I knew you'd be
part of this thing what's going on with
this tomorrow
comedy gives back as an organization
that helps out comedians who aren't
working they were sick and nobody's
working right now luckily I have a
cushion but there's a lot of comics that
are really stuck right now so we're
gonna raise money for them which is a
good idea but if you think about it the
ones who are really suffering are the
close-up magicians right now they are
making zero money right so basically
people can tune in and what who's who's
gonna be at the mic tomorrow I mean and
what's it gonna look like is it just
everybody from their own spots just
surfing in or streaming in and just
doing their stuff Dave Attell and I are
gonna go side by side via zoom and bump
mics virtually Bob Saget yeah what is
that gonna do our bumping mic show what
time is right in the live stream okay I
think it's somewhere in the first hour
but I'm not sure it's like a three or
four hour telethon literally a telethon
on the telephone right it'll be fun okay
fantastic
I know what you've been up to lately you
had a heck of an April Fool's joke that
you pulled on everybody Jeffery did you
not I couldn't believe it I've never
pranked anybody in my life that works so
well so on your podcast you made it seem
like you caught you spoke to the tiger
king himself from his cell is that is
that correct yeah I do I do a podcast
out of my out of my house ran
and my buddy Jeremiah Watkins does a
dead-on impression of the tiger kingjoe
exotic I was like let me just call
Jeremiah as Joe exotic and say it's that
I used my contacts from roasting
prisoners in Texas where this guy is how
right and and and see if people buy into
it and we did a 15-minute interview and
Jeremiah was so hilarious and sounded so
much like the guy that a lot like
hundreds of thousands of people bought
into including harvey levin from TMZ
[Laughter]
some of the Easter eggs that might have
been you know included in that just
total gags like that that you'd think
that nobody would buy what was happening
right he was screaming how he was gonna
get out of jail and killed Carroll
basket he was saying things that no
lawyer would ever let him say you know
he committed crimes during the interview
and then he had a guitar and started
singing I was like what prison whatever
less I think people people people love
this maniac so much they they just they
went with it right and I like the I
guess the still photograph that you had
him on a payphone made it look like it
was live even though clearly it wasn't
live I kind of liked what you did you
really had to be the value to it the
production value that's well it's worth
a listen it's called thick-skinned which
are broth Wednesday's episode called
tiger King cause Jeff Ross and the best
part is like if you look at I mean
people really first of all I love
animals rich I would never have this
this maniac on my on my podcast this
guy's in prison for you know abusing
animals and humans by the way right but
you know there's seven episodes that
have completely captivated the public so
I was like this is going to be a fun a
fun way to do the podcast and make some
laughs and you know April Fool's Day is
my comedy anniversary
but I mean this is my first year in 31
years my first time onstage was April
Fool's Day 1989 we're at the ye olde
triple in on 54th Street in Manhattan
followed a bongo player Jeff Schultz a
fat chubby loser living in New Jersey
with my grandfather yeah and and my
buddy mark Chapin talked me into taking
a comedy class and the day before our
graduation I went to my first open mic
on March 31st 1989 but then I didn't get
on till 1:00 a.m. so officially April
Fool's Day yes and it was my first time
onstage and I did pretty well actually
there was a couple Navy guys in town for
Fleet Week as I recall and my jokes
weren't working but I started making fun
of these guys for having mustard stains
on their what you know insult kind the
roastmaster general was born and what
was the first time you I said I texted
you a youtube link I had I don't know
what pops up cuz I I do like the old
Johnny Carson shows of Buddy Hackett and
I sent that to you because I know Buddy
Hackett was you know was one of your
idols what was the first time you met
Rickles you got a good Rickles story
give me your favorite Rickles story
Geoffrey the first time I met Rickles
was at the American comedy awards that
they used to do it in Hollywood and I
was with my pal Adam Ferrara who was
getting a comedian of the Year young
comedian kind of award and I was this
plus one we had our rented tuxedos we
walk into the ballroom
and we're a table 239 Don Rickles is a
table one so we work our way up to the
front and Don sees these two comedians
coming at him out of the side of his eye
and just as we're about to go mr.
Rickles Don looks at us and goes all
right kids don't make a thing
[Laughter]
yeah and you know we felt like part of a
club he's very warm to us and I wound up
performing for him and with him many
many times I always say he had the black
belt in busting balls
I missed the truth-tellers right now
Joan Rivers I was thinking about
yesterday I saw that so interesting
right now talking about the world you
know comedy it's as journalism gets so
opinionated it's kind of interesting to
see the comics being brutally honest and
unfiltered and and we don't have to
worry about corporate sponsors usually
and we you know we get to speak our mind
and I think it's really important and
that's why another reason I thought the
comedy gives back laughs bethe valence
important because comics don't have a
union we don't really look out no one
looks out for us we're like a cult we
have to look out for each other
well you know we had bill burr on an
hour too and I just wanted to have you
on for sure just to connect with you I
know of and texting back and forth with
you I I want to come on your pod I I
will play myself not in jail I I rescue
two dogs I love animals
it'll be good what you jog yesterday did
you really congrats girlfriend brought
home a a dirty mangy old blind limping
dog okay who smells like King Kong's
armpit but I love her already it's been
one day what's her name what's your name
her her name I named her Rona Rona you
know there's a silver lining to all this
darkness and I think that's that we're
appreciating life a little bit more and
each other a little bit more well I
can't wait to watch tomorrow at 7:00
Eastern Time everybody go to comedy
gives back calm to find out more how you
can give and how you can watch that live
stream of comics star
tomorrow at 7 p.m. as you said Ditka
Jeff Ross I can't wait to touch all your
faces again as you tweeted out yesterday
you're the best you're the one and only
one more thing my girlfriend and I
here's another quarantine tip to let
keep your relationship hot yeah my
girlfriend I have been role playing and
last night we dressed up as the two
popes the one and only Jeffrey Ross that
was amazing I love that guy